Crawley back with you for Chapter 2.
When a tragic accident strikes, the damage ripples outward. We categorize these into two types of losses.
First are direct losses. These are the devastating physical blows: accidental loss of life, permanent disablement, or the physical dismemberment of limbs.
Second are indirect losses. These hit the family survival funds, such as massive medical expenses or the sudden loss of income because the client is physically unable to engage in their profession.
The basic PA policy covers accidental death provided the death occurs within a specific window, usually 180 days from the date of the accident. It also covers permanent disablement.
The payouts for lost limbs follow a strict percentage table. For example, losing both feet or total sight in both eyes pays 100% of the sum. Losing an arm at or above the elbow pays 70%, while losing a thumb pays 15%.
To build a stronger shield for your client, you can add optional covers. This includes temporary disablement to replace lost weekly income, medical reimbursement, burial benefits, and even coverage for unprovoked murder or assault.
However, be aware that the murder and assault extension carries strict regional exclusions such as parts of Samar, Basilan, and the Sulu Archipelago.
There are also hard boundaries to the policy itself. While PA covers your client 24 hours a day, 365 days a year, anywhere in the world, it strictly excludes sickness.
It also will not cover war, military duty, self-inflicted injuries, or hazardous lifestyles like scuba diving or skydiving.